what is your background
my background is a kidnap for ransom
negotiator or a crisis response
consultant as is known in the industry
kidnap for ransom is that is that a
specific subset of kidnap negotiating
when you're saying please things like
extortion as well the uh typical you
know for a shop owner that Mafia used to
get involved in or maybe a Cyber attack
um but yeah pretty much every single
kidnapping would involve some kind of
Ransom demand hence kidnap for ransom
interesting it yeah it's I suppose it's
when you think about kidnapping
in movies there's kidnaps that happen
because there's just evil people out
there but I suppose that is it right to
Guess that in the real world most
kidnaps the kidnapper actually has some
sort of end goal that they want they're
not just doing it because they're a
bastard
there may be elements of that but at the
end of the day it's pretty much a
business transaction now if you're the
hostage or you're the family of the
hostage it may be more than that but in
reality and certainly from my
perspective as The Negotiator this is
just a business deal we need to find a
solution to as quickly as possible
how many people were at your level uh
when you were doing this role
well I'm not sure if it's true but we
were told on day one that more people
have been to the International Space
Station than do this as full-time tier
one professional negotiators so he said
he sounded good it's stroke our egos
um which actually needed some very small
team of Highly switched on uh people
who've got each other's backs but become
very very proficient
in that certain skill set
what is the
Avatar what's the classic British
negotiator person where are they from
what's their background what's their
personality like what's their demeanor
all that yeah well fully enough when I
was at school I went to see the careers
advisor then go Scott you could be a
train driver a pilot a negotiator
so most people it's their second or
third career whether it's in the
military as an investigative journalist
and mine was as a cop so I was a
detective for 16 years
I had a great time I love pretty much
every single day as a detective at
Scotland Yard and actually looking back
my career was very much around people so
whether or not it was running in four
months or taking a bit of time out to
becoming I was an interrogator in Iraq
for the military for a while
um or as a negotiator and so to all this
this real interest in what makes people
tick what makes them feel think feel and
act the way they do particularly in
times of stress crisis uncertainty
pretty much like the times we're living
in now to be honest
um and so having done that career and I
wanted a career change just turned 40
some people call it midlife crisis to go
and buy a Ferrari or marry a model I go
and join a cannot negotiation firm and
have a a second career and um I left on
the Thursday the police and on the
Monday I joined and they said Scott yeah
we're going to give you the best
negotiation training course in the world
which is actually in reality turned out
to three live kidnappings that I was
shattering one in the Philippines into
Nigeria
baptism of fire I think it's called is
it as glamorous as it is in the movies
it depends if you think
hanging around for a couple of weeks
just sitting around is glamorous I don't
know depends what your idea of fun is
it's one of those things where there's
lots of
record hurry up and wait
okay so in the first 24 hours of a
kidnapping taking place you need to get
on the plane or get on the phone
reassure the family reassure the company
right we've got this this is going to be
the strategy I'm here to advise you I'm
not going to tell you what to do or make
decisions but I'll give you some
recommendations pros and cons Etc
and then we all want to take a nice big
deep breath and just relax as much as
possible we've got our strategy we know
what we're going to say on the first
call now we just need to look after
ourselves and get into some kind of
Rhythm and that's fine everybody gets
used to that for the week first week 10
days whilst and waiting for a call
and the phone does ring
and then it's like headless chickens and
running around and the heartbeat's going
but having done it quite a few times now
even at times and maybe like a swan
gliding gracefully but underneath the
heart pounding actually it's muscle
memory you get right here I've been here
before we know what we need to do trust
the training trust the process
and we're off and running
you as a negotiator you just insinuated
there that not only dealing with the
kidnapper but you're also potentially
dealing internally with uh stakeholders
in what is what has been kidnapped is
that right
yeah dealing with the kidnappers is the
easy bit
we can't honestly it I can't tell you
enough questions it's the easy bit
because it's a business transaction okay
if we mess it up people could die and
all of the considerations which are
going to a bit later if we get on to it
in terms of logistics
but the crisis within the crisis if you
think about it you've got egos internal
politics High emotion
in probably the most stressful
circumstances these people are ever
going to face
and so I'm almost in the middle of this
so it's about developing
this sensory acuity you're talking about
you know what is the kind of person who
who gets into this field and is good at
it it's somebody with that antennae it
can go right
something's going on with that person
over there their their mannerisms all
their energy is not congruent what
they're saying or they're getting a bit
agitated and so he's constantly picking
up on these cues so you can then a make
sure that you're balanced yourself
emotionally but more importantly you can
somehow reduce their anxiety and stress
and overwhelm to bring about that
objective rational thinking which is
what we want cool calm heads which is
why I named the book called out of chaos
because that's ultimately what this is
is we want to bring some order out of
what is a very chaotic and stressful
circumstances maybe it is more like the
Hollywood movies than you thought then
because in the movies there's always
it's not just the politic with the
kidnapper it's the internal strife
that's going on because the chief of
police has come down and the CIA and the
FBI they both believe that this is their
case and who's this Renegade guy like
why is why is Dwayne The Rock Johnson
why is he taking this role or whatever
whatever it might be so all of that all
of that what do you think that
negotiators know about human nature that
most normal people don't
I think there's an unbelievable
resilience mentally and emotionally
within all of us I've seen people held
captive for months
at a time Who come out pretty much
unscathed
it's because their mindset the way they
frame this the meaning they've given
their circumstances has meant they can
come out and actually live just as good
if not a better life as a result of
their experience
and actually no matter what is thrown in
front of us
the challenges the issues the problems
actually we're more than capable of
overcoming them you know there's nothing
that is insurmountable
and actually we're very adaptable agile
creatures if we can just turn down that
lousy narrative that lousy story we've
got going on inside of our heads about
you know we're not good enough it's not
going to work
blah blah blah
talk to me about some of the highest
pressure situations that you've been in
an illustrious career of dealing with
crazy different circumstances
probably my first case actually is when
I was at Scotland Yard and it's based in
a in a cramped flat in London and one of
the younger Sons had been taken by a
rival drug gang
and so after a couple of days when this
small flat lots of family members around
High motion
and we're coaching myself my colleague
are coaching the other brother as the
communicator because obviously we don't
want to advertise that police are
involved
and then the threats start coming in
and there's a bit of almost like a mock
execution the background we can hear the
uh the hostage in a bit of pain
and then the kidnappers say right we
know where you are and they gave the
address and we know you're working with
the police we're going to send some guys
around to spray the place with a Mac 10
machine gun and they're on the way right
now
and I'm thinking right okay a Mac 10
machine gun is like the weapon of choice
of gang members in London it's from the
most deadliest weapons you can ever use
particularly in the hands of people
aren't very good with using it I'm
thinking Hmm this is an interesting set
of circumstances to be in here and I
looked up a colleague and he looks at me
and were like is this a bluff are they
just trying to trying to have us over
here
but we didn't take any chances so very
quickly because at the time I'm a member
of the biggest gang in London the
Metropolitan Police so we actually got
two big on response Vehicles we've got
more guns than you yeah and there was
literally six heavily armed so 19
officers there and actually that blew
our cover in a week so we wanted to be
discreet but far better that than
you know a family full of
um uh victims in a flat some way
including myself and my colleague so
that was the first how did that end up
getting resolved
oh in the end we managed to get the uh
the brother back
um and that's actually interesting in
the UK or the US
in kidnappings or hostage takings
normally there's some kind of Hostage
rescue okay
because we've got the best teams best
SWAT teams in the world
whereas in other parts of the world
I'd always stress for a negotiated
settlement here because there's a 93
chance
of a successful resolution that way I
would not trust many many governments
and units around the world to conduct
the hostage rescue it's just fraught
with too many dangers but in the UK
that's pretty much how they will they
will pan out and so our job is actually
see if we can negotiate the release but
it's also to buy time as well
what was that story of a pirate hijacked
ship thing that you were involved in
there's been a few
um
well there's one where
um six hostages got taken
um and they got taken off the ship and
into West African country which won't be
a surprise to people and
um
and the conversation we didn't hear
anything about 10 days two weeks and the
negotiation start
um
but then after one point because the
kidnappers weren't getting what they
wanted you know they came in at three
million dollars or something and we're
offing at that point about seventy
thousand because it's about managing
expectations
um and after the point the kidnap has
gotten really frustrated
and then when we on the call one day the
guy I'm using as a communicator because
the language barrier
he says well you know you must look
after our crew my friends there your
responsibility whilst you've got them
held hostage
and then there's this really booming
voice from the kidnap on the other side
go no
they're yours we want the money by the
end of the week or they will die
and you could hear a pin drop that is
until
this guy Mr John I'll call him his fist
came banging down on the table and I'm
realized in that moment it's about to
come my way as well
and he turns around and says how can you
sit there Mr Scott
so car when my friends are gonna die now
I know they're not gonna die I know full
well this is just a tactic but he stands
up and walks out
and in that moment I know right okay I
need to take a bit of initiative here in
a calculated risk
which is I need I can leave the
kidnappers they're good for 24 36 48
hours we're in a good position with them
in terms of negotiation my primary aim
is to look after Mr John
because if I can't get him on board if I
can't get him to cooperate if I can't
re-establish trust with him
we're going to go nowhere and the
hostages are going to die
so I'm there sitting down with him doing
all of the you know all the active
listening all the J I mean genuinely
empathizing with him and validating
where he's at and then you know the next
day the day after he um he comes in
showered shaved new man and then we get
a deal and the hostages oh dude I'm so
fascinated by the fact that most of your
job isn't negotiating with the
kidnappers but it's negotiating with the
internal politics I think that's such a
such a really great takeaway and it's so
um representative or symbolic of many of
the challenges that we come up against
whether it be in our personal lives
whether it be in business dealings that
we always see the world outside as the
adversary or as the enemy uh there's
this really great story from uh Winston
Churchill
and he is in the 40s taking a uh young
MP through the houses of Parliament and
he's explode this is the [__] toilets
and this is where you know we we have
lunch and this is whatever and they
enter into uh the chambers and this
young MP who's sort of all full of
testosterone he starts gesturing at the
other benches and he keeps calling them
the enemy and Churchill turns to him and
says that's the opposition Dear Boy the
enemy is behind you and I think it's
just so
perfectly symbolic of how we become our
own worst enemies uh day to day in our
own lives we don't help ourselves the
way that we should do
um most of the business problems that I
see uh occurred due to inefficiencies or
lack of good communication and and
politics and strife that go on inside of
a company not between companies like you
know that the people that are out there
have there is something that they need
from you there is something that they
want and the parameters are relatively
fixed it's all of the Myriad different
dials and knobs that are going on inside
those are the the tides that are turning
so one of the other things you mentioned
before which I think is a really really
interesting uh line of this
you've got certain types of kidnapping
situations held for ransom where it's an
individual but then there are other ones
where the company data presumably
um there was that one what was that
pipeline in America that got done and it
was for Bitcoin yeah
um so you have scenarios like this what
is the difference
in the um what are the differences
between those two different kinds of
scenarios okay let's take the Cyber
extortion for example it is normally a
reputational risk then I appreciate that
staring kidnapping but from a cyber
extortion normally data has been
extracted and or encrypted as well and
usually there's some reputational risk
to the company the longer it continues
or they just can't do business they're
going to lose money as well
it changes slightly when you're dealing
with maybe Healthcare which we've seen
that a lot of ransomware attacks over
the last few years there's one a cry in
others
um and so it's slightly different there
whereas in a kidnap negotiation there's
only going to be the hostage they can't
copy them they can't keep clones of them
so when we negotiate the release and
we've physically got the hostage we know
we're good whereas if we pay a ransom to
an extortionist in a cyber case
okay the business model is they're more
often than not going to keep their word
because no one's going to pay them again
in future
but there's no guarantees I haven't made
a copy or kept a copy uh back for
releasing it on the dark web or to sell
it to competitors so it's slightly
Nuance there but like in anything I say
to the clients there's no guarantees
here there's never going to be 100 you
just need to
on the balance of probabilities do a
risk cost benefit analysis and work out
what you want to do do you want to
negotiate and engage but this is costing
you maybe let's say half a million
dollars a day in Lost opportunity costs
but how much is the extortion demand for
and what we don't know we're not checked
okay well maybe we want to check oh it's
for 20 000 Euros okay well my opinion my
advice to you is it's up to you you may
want to consider paying that yeah if
it's costing you are familiar okay
um okay I'm simplifying the example
there but it's all these things I need
to weigh up and actually can we make
sure that the
RIT system is clean and doesn't have any
kind of malignant malware put in there
for example have you watched
hijacked on Apple TV
I have of course you have I absolutely
love this series at the moment I think
maybe five episodes are out or six
episodes are out at the moment as we're
doing it
um so for the people that don't know
Idris Elba handsome black man gets on a
plane from Dubai to the UK and uh the
plane gets hijacked by some some
bastards uh most of whom are from London
but one of whom is a Geordie so I I'm
fully supportive of her
and Idris then begins he is a I think
he's a negotiator for high stakes
mergers and Acquisitions and stuff like
that sometimes hostile takeovers and
stuff too uh I have you noticed in that
series how accurate do you think they
have portrayed the industry that you
know so well do you think Idris is is
doing a good job with his negotiation
skills
but enough I was interviewed by The
Daily Telegraph the newspaper here in
the UK last week on this around
as an entertainment value
it is outstanding it's exceptional
writing you know bear in mind I do this
for a living I've been involved in one
hijacking before
I'm still hooked okay as a series but
that's where it ends oh no Idris what
were the absurdity level is as high as
the altitude of the plane okay because
if I'm on if I'm a passenger if I lead
to a seller on board okay I mean I
probably really wouldn't be doing the
things he's doing I'll be making sure
I'm staying calm I'm really showing
other people I'm not going to antagonize
the hijackers let alone take the gun off
them and hand it back and all this sort
of stuff he's done
that said if it was a kind of 9 11
scenario where I think hey
they're gonna crash this plane and
that's a different situation that's a
different scenario and I think actually
a lot of people on board flights now
would do something about it if they
thought they're gonna crash this plane
there'd be a bit of a mutant on the
plane I reckon
but in terms of negotiation
no that said what he is good at is
getting into the minds of the hijackers
what makes them tick where's the
leverage which he did and without
spoiling anything for people having seen
it in terms of the relationship between
the brothers on the plane for example
and so that is one of the first golden
rules of negotiation is
well actually I'm not going to be as
arrogant enough to think it's all about
me I need to understand what makes the
person tick what are their beliefs
motivations needs that are there often
below the surface but I need to get
curious to find them out so that's that
another bit I'd say about the series is
in terms of the uh
the chaos that's going on back in London
and trying to manage it that is normally
how the first
few hours of any kind of Crisis look
sounds and feels like until it gets into
a steady rhythm yeah again you know
hierarchies of power it's like the
foreign secretaries getting involved the
home secretaries getting involved people
are getting Ransom notes and um again I
suppose
it doesn't matter each time that a
kidnapping occurs there is only a very
small number of people that have done
this before you your support team but
unless you're really really Reckless
it's probably the first time you've been
kidnapped and it's probably the first
time that your family has had to deal
with the kidnapping which means that it
must feel a little bit like Groundhog
Day every single time having to go
through this same rigmarole of okay so
step one we speak and explain step two
we calm down and and contain step three
we do the whatever whatever
um and yeah the um
externalities internally of that okay so
we've we've sort of danced around some
of the stories when it comes to the nuts
and bolts of persuasion and negotiating
how do you
um conceptualize the the fundamentals of
it like what are the core components or
what is the science behind negotiating
often people say to me Scott what is
what is I need to say what can I say to
get money off or get an upgrade and all
this kind of stuff which is a starter I
get asked all the time and I always turn
around and go you're asking the wrong
question
because you're wrapping it all around
you and what you want we're actually why
don't you ask okay how can I really find
out what's going on for the other person
or what they value the most or how can I
listen better which goes back to the
golden rule of it's not about you
you know again it's a cliche with a
cliche for a reason seek first or
understand before being understood
um and that way the other side will
actually tell you what their pain points
are what they're looking for what would
be a good deal for them if you listen
properly and in the book I talk about
level five listening you know the top
few levels are all about all about you
where you're listening for the gist or
you're listening waiting to talk so you
can rebut what they're saying whereas
actually we want to go below that and
listen to
the emotion maybe the underlying emotion
that's not being expressed
and then really what's their model of
the world what's their beliefs what
their rules
and with the way we do that is yes by
asking really powerful open questions
but by some simple tools and techniques
that have been around for decades you
know the the active listening techniques
such as
um you know you're paraphrasing or
you're labeling and this is you just
being curious rather than assuming you
know what they mean when they say it dig
into those techniques for me
paraphrasing yeah
so labeling would be saying emotional
labeling
so if I'm sensing your little frustrated
with something right now I'll say with
this conversation I would just say
something like you sound a lot
frustrated here Chris it seems like
you've been annoyed or it seems like
I've actually missed something here and
you may go no no it's not that it's this
instead because we have a saying that we
need to name it to tame it if we can't
name it the emotion
we can't tame it
and it's like the big elephant in the
room you know when the emotions there
somebody is not quite in a good place we
kind of skirt around the issue whereas
actually we want to call it out we want
to name it so we can tame it for
ourselves particularly you know tuning
into what's going on for you but
particularly with the other person but
that's not a one-time tick box exercise
it's continuous through your negotiation
or through your communication that's the
first thing
and then the paraphrasing or the
summarizing
is just reflecting back your
understanding of what the other person
is saying and this is particularly
helpful if people go on for quite a long
time I deal with my kids I've got two
teenagers and they just like to talk and
talk and talk and talk and I have to
interrupt them I'm going okay so what
you're saying is this this this and this
and they go yeah that's it
great
so there are those two techniques for
example very on that actually doesn't
really quickly sorry is
again the caveat I give to people is
again don't use this as a tick list oh I
need to use paraphrasing or minimal
encourages such as saying okay I'm not
in my head I just need to just genuinely
listen and be curious about the person
and I'll do a lot of that stuff
automatically
um yeah so be led by the genuine desire
to know what it is that they want when
it comes to you mentioned before open
questions as being one of them what are
some of your favorite questions or
question types that people should use in
order to find out what it is that the
other person wants
okay it's model what or how questions
really you know those seven Kipling's
friends really around okay well what
does that look like for you or how are
we going to make that happen or how
would you know
that you've got what you wanted people
say you know some of my clients now
they'll go well I wanna
you know I want to lose weight or I want
to achieve this business thing okay well
how would you know then you've achieved
it what needs to happen so it's getting
them to do the heavy lifting
intellectually to work through exactly
what does that look sound and feel like
that's what you want to tap into really
when I do uh partner negotiations for
the show and this for the fledgling
content creators that are listening is a
really really great tool if you're
having a discussion with a partner
especially if it's a new one or even if
it's just a renewal with an existing
partner one of the first questions I
always ask to absolutely everybody is
what would success look like and that
helps me to work out okay this
particular company is really really
interested in uh breaking into the
United States Market this company is
looking to improve their brand Equity
this company wants to uh sell in 18
months times they're trying to drive top
line revenue they're trying to do
whatever whatever and it gives me so
much information but you're right as
well by saying what would success look
like to you what is it that you want out
of this how will you know when we have
reached it
first off it it does cause them to do
the heavy lifting secondly it protects
you from making assumptions that could
be incorrect and thirdly it actually
ensures that they know what it is that
they want a lot of the time people come
into a negotiation and they just they
want
thing I just want more oh stuck more
what what is it that you need like and
by forcing them to actually assess what
it is you create a parameter from which
you can then measure performance or
success
and often people haven't asked those
questions of themselves in the first
place correct correct yeah they want I
want Financial Freedom okay to do what
well you know just travel more have more
freedom okay well
what does freedom look like for you what
does that mean you know those kind of
questions where people go oh right yeah
I've never really thought of that I
don't know okay well there you go
what about building Rapport is that done
through the same way or is there a
different strategy when it comes to that
without and to repeat myself here it's
not a tick box exercise people think oh
I've got Rapport that's it no I'm good
it's a continuous process of where you
are in alignment with wherever you're
talking to now Rapport can be you could
be having an argument with somebody but
you could be in Rapport depending on how
you're having the argument
and so it is a vital step in bringing
about
that cooperational collaboration so if
you imagine at one end you've got all
these active listening skills that we've
touched on you're building the empathy
or you're demonstrating empathy because
empathies are doing word
you're then building the rapport and
then you bring a bit you you've earned
the right you've earned the trust
start maybe influencing and persuading
somebody to change their behavior
perhaps
But ultimately to bring about
cooperation and collaboration so in the
case I gave earlier that could be Mr
John my Communicator it could be with
the kidnappers and this is particularly
powerful if you disagree with somebody
that you have a conversation with
because then it just demonstrates hey
you can get out of your own way and park
your own ego but secondly actually I
might disagree with you but I respect
you as a person as a human being
therefore I'm not a threat to you so you
can balance your nervous system out yeah
I'm going to come back out fighting
towards me and then we can try and find
some kind of collaboration and that's
how it works um yeah it reminds me of
that the difference between the
opposition and the enemy that with one
of them you are playing a game you know
the opposition is Roger Federer versus
Novak Djokovic right in a game but
they're playing the game together There
are rules of the game there is expected
conduct there is a degree of mutual
respect each wants to win and each would
probably happily [__] the other one over
to win but at least you know kind of
what to expect it's when those rules go
completely out of the window and Federer
jumps over the net and blams him in the
face that's when it becomes a different
sort of conversation and thinking as
well about
how people should prepare themselves
before they go into a negotiation at one
of my friends Alex homozy says that you
would be absolutely amazed how much
better you perform with just 15 minutes
of preparation before you do anything
and it's so true that
the bar is set so unbelievably low and
your short-term memory is really good
even people that say that they've got
[__] memories your short-term memories
awesome you can keep a hold of you know
five things a couple of little trip
wires in your mind someone knocks one of
them over and that's interesting I know
that you've got a golden retriever
actually did you you did you go oh my
God look at all of the preparations I
read that 10 minutes ago so
talk to me about what people should be
doing before they go into it's a a job
interview it's a renegotiation for their
car deal it's them looking to get a pay
increase it's them looking to do a
complaint it's them giving a business
presentation
what are you doing in order to set
yourself
um physiologically to keep the nerves
nice and calm to stay cool but it once
you get in there stuff just starts
happening it's the before time I think
where the highest amount of discomfort
is felt
yeah there's a couple of parts of that
the first one is accepting that you
might get a bit nervous the emotions are
going to show up in you and the other
person this is particularly no difficult
conversations so except that you might
be uncomfortable at times in it but
that's okay
and once you've done that you know well
actually I need to manage my own
emotions first and that could be some
breathing techniques for example just to
kind of regulate when you're in there
but once you are in there it's the
preparation is key and we used to call
it the bunch of fives you know we used
to have you know hold our hands up these
five fingers four things in a thumb a
bunch of fives and they were okay what
are the top three to five
challenges issues threats that in my
case the kidnappers or the hostess
takers might Levy against me as a
negotiator if I can think about what
those are ahead of time
I don't have to think on the hoof I can
actually plan my answer to that
accordingly and the same applies in any
kind of business meeting or in the
examples that you gave if I can think
okay what are the likely objections
perhaps to me asking for a pay rise what
might my boss say if I was my boss and I
wanted to turn this down what might I
say because by working out what these
could be ahead of time means I can do my
research I can do my preparation so when
that that question comes to you or that
challenge comes to you it doesn't take
you by surprise and you can just deal
with it
in your flow
very interesting okay so let's say that
you're having a discussion with somebody
and the emotions really do start flying
that they're particularly difficult
interlocutor
what can be done to bring down the
volume the intensity of that situation
both externally to them and then
internally in terms of your emotional
control during the during the event
I call it the immediate action drill or
the Ia drill and it's similar just keep
in the back pocket metaphorically all
the time there's three steps to it if I
can feel this is just spiraling a bit
out of control here either for me or for
them or just interrupt the pattern so if
I'm sat down or just stand up take a
couple of breaths and might go outside
or just say excuse me I just need to go
and get some fresh air I might go for a
short walk
I might just turn on some random music
just to interrupt that pattern to get
you out of that lousy state that that
whoever's in
then the second thing is is realize that
that wave of emotion the court is all
that's running through your body
theoretically it lasts for 90 seconds
biologically that's all it goes for your
body for when you get that trigger
any longer and you realize you're just
press pressing repeat inside your head
on that story
so knowing that it's tuning into your
body okay
what's showing up okay there's a
churning in my stomach or tension across
my shoulders I'm just going to sit with
that for a minute or so and I'm just
going to have this complete awareness
I'm going to drop the reason why
we call it feel the feeling and drop the
story just really feel it 90 seconds two
minutes tops
and then that will balance your nervous
system and then you can ask the third
step is ask some better questions okay
what was all that about where did that
come from
and usually it's something within
yourself and not the other person which
is a great Insight usually so your game
is bringing more curiosity than
assumption to the table to interrupt the
pattern we ride the wave imagine you're
a surfer or a skier for 90 seconds and
then you're asked some really powerful
questions afterwards wouldn't you
balanced and then you can come back in
whether or not it's five minutes later
five hours or five days later and pick
up where you left off far better that
than what usually happens particularly
from family set things is there's lots
of naming shaming blaming shouting you
know I'm sure we've all been been both
on the receiving end on the giving end
of those
I like feel the feeling and drop the
story I think that's a lovely cue and I
had Sam Harris on the show not long ago
he's got this really great example he
uses where he says
um imagine that you've just finished a
hard workout and you're laid on the
floor doing a sweat Angel and your lungs
are burning and you're sweating and you
can taste metal in the back of your
throat your heart rate at 175.
that is actually quite an enjoyable
experience in in some regards because
you feel proud of what you've done you
know that you've worked hard for it you
are contributing to your health being
better this is something that you can be
proud of if this happens spontaneously
while you are sat in traffic you would
think what the [__] is going on I need
to crash through all of these cars and
get myself to the hospital so the story
that you tell yourself about your
experience largely determines your
experience of it and I think allowing
yourself to just sit with disco it's
like okay so your heart rate's high and
you you feel flush
and
okay so you feel angry at this person
and there is as soon as you ask that
next question of so what like what what
do what does this mean it's just a
sensation that's arisen
am I able to make a better decision when
I'm like this or if I'm able to get
myself through the other side of this by
just allowing it to wash over me and I
like the idea of of a uh a surfer
analogy too you've got this concept of a
red Center as well is that similar
yeah I mean red Center physically is the
geographical location where the
negotiation will take place so it could
be a family kitchen dining table office
but over the years
I just thought you know what there's
more to this it's actually something
within all of us deep within us this
ability to
you know to rely on Equanimity more than
anything else to be balanced to be calm
at the sense of a raging Storm around us
because is it fair to say that things
are not going to go according to plan it
doesn't have to be in a kidnap
negotiation it could be with your kids
with traffic with work and so if we
accept that actually we can tap into
this inner part of us this red Center
call it and that's where all our tools
and techniques that we've picked up over
the years are just lying there waiting
for us to use them but we just need to
go looking for it and it's there within
us all the time and so that is about
being able to be calm regulate a nervous
system and then once we've done that
re-engage and do whatever it is we need
to do
talk to me about this tension between
empathy which is presumably useful at
understanding what the other person is
feeling but being sufficiently detached
that you can make rational decisions it
feels to me like there is uh there's a
little bit of a battle going on between
these two things too much empathy you're
so invested that now you're unable to to
do the drop the story feel the feelings
thing
yeah I mentioned this in the book The
caveat around sympathy empathy and
compassion and there's a danger we get
lost in semantics here
so really the way I sum it all up is
empathy particularly when I'm
negotiating
it's I don't have to actually feel your
pain or care about your pain actually I
just need to demonstrate I understand
how I get where you're coming from
and to the point where you go ah Scott
gets me and again this is particularly
powerful if we disagree on something now
I don't like the kidnapper I've got
nothing in common with him he's
threatening to execute the hostages and
he would if could get away with it and
he just wants money for doing this now I
need to demonstrate empathy to him
otherwise he's not going to agree to
they're always going to take a lot
longer and a lot more pain to get the
deal
I don't need to sympathize with him and
I'm not necessarily need to bring some
compassion either so with the empathies
that's just me demonstrating my
understanding or reflecting back what
the other person is feeling
I understand one of the other
um ideas that I've got in my head here
is that listening as a skill that can be
developed you know as you're listening
you're being passive the person is just
allowing things to wash over you but you
have this conception I think it's quite
right between proactive listening and
just listening or passive listening and
and my trade is in listening right this
is what I do I listen I listen to the
guest and I was really trying to reflect
on what what I try and and pick out of
of the people that I'm listening to it
it kind of gives me the sense that the
bar is set so low for good listening
that there shouldn't really be such a
thing as proactive listening the only
reason that that exists is because most
listening is people waiting for their
turn to speak next or getting distracted
when they should actually be paying
attention
absolutely it's not rocket science but
our attention span is so low now is that
we're constantly thinking oh yeah we
should just hurry up and get to the
point you know I've got 13 other things
I need to do in the next minute or the
danger is the first 10 to 15 words of
what you're saying I'm now assuming I
know what you mean and I'll try and
finish a sentence for you or I'll come
back with a response
whereas actually we just need to perhaps
slow down or or maybe just give a little
breath after you've finished and then
before I start talking but we just seem
to struggle to do that these days
yeah I um you mentioned it earlier on
but it's something that I use a lot I
guess the audience will never actually
get to be able to see this although my
editor deanwell and the guests that come
on the show if the uh other camera was
on while the guest is talking I would
look like Churchill the nodding dog
because for a lot of the time I'm just
can yep keep going I can hear you this
is good I can do the thing and I'm just
bouncing my head up and down
um but I realized first off Oprah does
it and Oprah is a pretty good
interviewer regardless of what you think
about her politics and secondly
if you're listening to somebody speak
especially if it's being recorded for
any reason
if you have any verbal interjections
yeah I understand okay like all of this
it kind of disrupts the listening
experience so you get to continue yep
I'm here I'm still listening to you this
is me being active oh that was an
interesting point and I'll nod in a
slightly different manner like an entire
repertoire of like 15 different nods
that I can pull out of the out of the
Armory and um yeah I think the nod a uh
widely underused tool in the Arsenal of
the potential listener
it is and it goes back to the point I
made at the start of the interview
whereas
these techniques are great you need to
to know the rules before you can break
the rules and what I mean by that is
if you are genuinely curious about what
the other person is saying and you want
to find out what okay what's important
to them what what's this about for you
I'm going to be nodding without even
realizing it's like mirroring body
language there's nothing more clunky oh
Chris has folded his arms okay I need to
fold my arms it's just no stop anybody
out there has listened to any courses or
any books just stop right now just take
a genuine empathetic interest into the
person and you will do that naturally
Danny Trejo the guy that played Machete
you know him
Hollywood actor massive chest tattooed
terrifying terrifying human he was on
the show last year and he was I asked
him about his introduction into
Hollywood so he starts acting but he's
been in jail he was a gang banger uh you
know living in LA and um
I asked him about this transition from
being a muggle like us to being someone
that acts on the Silver Screen he's
opposite Nick Cage and he's in these
huge movies and Productions
and you know he didn't have time to go
through the Myriad requisite acting
schools as a kid and John Bernthal went
out to Russia and learned like ballet
for a year before he even began acting
all you know the
um upbringing he didn't have it and I
asked him about what it is that he did
and he said well if the scene needs me
to go in sit down pick up a glass of
water and take a drink I don't act like
I'm going in sitting down picking up a
glass of water and taking a drink I just
do it I do the thing I'm not pretending
to do the thing I'm not acting to do the
thing I'm just doing the thing and there
is a
definitely an over complication that a
lot of people myself included we presume
that you have to go around the houses to
arrive back at just being honest I guess
truthful aligned working with Integrity
or virtue or whatever you want to call
it it's like what's the thing that
you're trying to appear like you're
doing
just do that like you don't need to
pretend to do the thing that you can
just you can just do the thing now it's
there's nuances here obviously like
being interested in somebody that's
boring is tough like you need to pretend
to be interested but there are things
that you can find that are interesting
about what the person is saying and the
more that you can do that I think you
can uh Channel your inner Danny Trejo a
little bit
yeah I agree completely I think we just
need to perhaps do less you know we want
to Stack all these great techniques
don't we but let's just remove some of
them and just do what we need to do
you must have a hierarchy of the biggest
negotiation mistakes or the things that
are able to uh the biggest no-nos that
you would have done whether it be high
stakes stuff or small steak stuff
um what are the most common errors that
people make that kind of ruins a
negotiation or at least damages it for a
little while
yeah it's certainly the not listening is
the is the key one but I think when
people give unsolicited advice as well
and start telling other people what they
should be doing I I think that um
particularly in a work environment or in
a friendly environment somebody comes to
you and want to kind of share a problem
or challenge with you and you just give
loads of advice about what they need to
do that never really goes down
particularly well
the ones where I've seen it unravel
really quickly
is when the emotions take over now we
all know now that we're emotional
creatures that think rather than
thinking creatures that feel we're
emotional beings this is what we do this
is how we make decisions and justify
them later but it's when it IT spirals
out of control and it's the fist bang on
the table or it's the verbal abuse or we
make it all about ourselves and about
ego and me me me
it just gets really messy and as I said
in in a kidnap scenario
people die if we mess that up so my
which is why I said at the beginning
about the crisis within the crisis I
need to make sure that the ego driven
CEO that's got into that top spot the
very skills actually don't come to Bear
here in this example I need him to be
low-key really generous team player all
that kind of stuff where actually I
wanna I'd rather speak to somebody two
three levels below him who's engaged and
wants to learn a lesson so I think
that's the key one is when we just allow
that emotion to run off on a course of
its own
looking at it from a more personal
perspective for yourself
what are the strategies that you've used
to overcome
uh regrets around the way that you
behaved during these sorts of
interactions
um or the I guess ambient anxiety when
you still have a bunch of open Loops you
part way through a negotiation you go to
bed to grab a couple of hours before you
wake up again to prep the communicator
for whatever's going on with these
Somali pirates
what are the tools that you've used to
be able to give yourself as much peace
of mind as you can in those interims or
if it's after the event to kind of be
able to wash yourself a bit and let go
two questions I asked myself I'm written
down in my journal at the back and every
time I get a new Journal I write them
down just as a reminder
so what now what and it can sound quite
harsh but actually just cuts through all
the BS in all the stories so at the end
of the day where
there's a courier who had the ransom
money on one case he was supposed to
call in every four hours on the way to
drop the money off with the kidnappers
four hours went by hidden phone
eight hours went by he didn't phone you
can see where this is going can't you
meanwhile the kidnappers are going
apoplectic they think we're going to
Ambush them we're going to rip them off
we're gonna Napalm their jungle Hideout
all this crazy stuff
and so at the end of the day I'm
thinking okay okay well so what now what
I need to remove that emotion from it so
I can make an objective rational thought
that a thinking and decision in the end
we did manage to get tribal outer to go
down speak to the chief of police who
then released The Courier and the money
I was gonna say where was The Courier
he was being detained by the um by the
local police for having carried a ton of
money in a briefcase or something yeah a
couple hundred thousand dollars from
across the border from one country to
the next which you shouldn't have done
but anyway we've managed to get them
released and we think great the Korea is
now gonna be on his way to drop the
money off but he wants no more to do
with it so he takes his cut and he legs
it meanwhile the kidnappers are not
having a decent day here
which comes back to that trust and the
cooperation the collaboration I spoke
about earlier because I'd established
that trust with the kidnap as I was
managed to allay their concerns for one
more day and so we needed to find
another Courier at the next day so I go
back to the to my room uh in the embassy
compound and I'm thinking right
what was going on there how did that
happen how do we not foresee that and
this brings this sense of constant and
never-ending Improvement whereas the
military guys will say the unrelenting
pursuit of Excellence okay so what it's
happened we can't do anything about it
now what we can do is how can we learn
from it and how can we make sure we
don't make those mistakes again and the
next day we found another Courier and he
got the money out he had to get a boat
out to sea to Waypoint where the
Handover was done
um so there's that and then after each
case it's it's sitting down doing an
after action review and you could do
this in your business or any kind of
family scenario you just review it okay
well what what well what could we do
better next time and not to take it
personally
I love it I love it very very cool Scott
Walker ladies and gentlemen where should
people go if they want to keep up to
date with all of the stuff that you're
doing
the website's probably the best place
scottwalkerbooks.co.uk and they can find
out more information there they can get
a hold of the book and the newsletter
and all the other good stuff
Scott I appreciate you thank you mate if
you enjoyed that episode then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe